foreign
most of rural kenya doesn't have access
to electricity this means the evenings
are full of darkness
here families rely on kerosene lamps
which are expensive and produce harmful
fumes
john wongary wanted to change that
my name is john mahiro angari i am the
founder of maguiro mean hydroelectricity
estimate
is
inspired by the dynamo on his brother's
bicycle that generated light whilst the
wheel turned john had an idea what if
that simple mechanism could be made
bigger and what could turn that wheel
this is what we call the liver
and the
fungus
[Music]
from there john started to make his
power plant with pieces of scrap
using the river john was able to move
the turbine thus generating electricity
slowly but surely magiro power started
to produce clean energy
this is my power station per house
are in a produce about 250 kilowatts in
a surprise about 250 households they are
connected
it may prove commercial
have a 10 degrees
where's the gengaste
upon you
economic nikita and bio highways
katherine
[Music]
you